okay so in this video I want to talk a
little bit more about glycosaminoglycans
specifically and kind of their structure
and function at least to introduce them
so glycosaminoglycans or G AG's also
known as mucopolysaccharides are hetero
polysaccharides that are long hence the
poly unbranched and linear and they're
really negatively charged and they
contain a repeating dissector ride you
name so I want to talk a little bit more
about what this repeating that cycle
ride unit is and when it kind of looks
like so the repeating that sakurai unit
of course disaccharide is reverses two
sugars that are linked together and this
unit repeats and specifically we have an
acidic sugar here linked to an amino
sugar and that is going to be the
disaccharide unit and that unit will
repeat so you'll have and and in
disaccharide units so there are two
possibilities for the acidic sugar and
they are shown here the first one is d
glucuronic acid which basically looks
like glucose it's got you know down up
down here as far as those OHS go and
it's a d sugar or a d sugar acid i
should say because carbon number six
here is up but it's not a ch2oh it's not
just the sugar it's a it's shown there's
a carboxylic acid now of course that can
be deprotonated in be co- and you'd have
d glucuronic neither way that's
represented as g LC coming from the
glucose in the you a meaning coming from
uronic acid okay so so as far as the
negative charge part of the reason that
glycosaminoglycans musical you know
being made up these disaccharide units
the part of the reason they're so
negatively charged is because what you
have a bunch of these acids deprotonated
and so that's part of the reason it's
actually circle that in a different
color let's just circle it in this color
and that's part of the reason these guys
are so negatively charged so that's one
of the possible acidic sugars
the other one is lig Raonic acid or li
durrani that should not say a larger on
that's weird viii refers of course the
fact that this would be deprotonated but
the difference here is that it looks
identical to do periodic acid except
that the carbon number six is down
instead of being up and so that is what
makes it el and but but I think that the
structure is really easy to remember
because it looks exactly like glucose
except that this is down instead of up
making it el and so again that can be
deprotonated and that very very much
like this guy is contributes that
negative charge and as far as the little
acronym here I D I do run eight and then
uronic acid okay you a now that's for
the acidic sugar now I do want to
mention here that this is a little
there's just a little star right here
there is an exception to to this little
repeating disaccharide unit and that's
something that will show later when we
actually show the the actual
disaccharide units of the different
classes of glycosaminoglycans which
we'll get to later but yeah those are
the two possible acidic sugars now there
are two possible amino sugars and
usually they are acetylated they're not
always use acetylated but they they
often are and I've drawn them both here
let's eat elated so the first one is n
acetyl glucosamine so it looks like
glucose down up down at these carbons
and it's a D sugar because that's ch2oh
is going up but it's a glucosamine
because this would normally be an NH 2
here at carbon number 2 but that is
acetylated so we can see that little
acetyl group shown there in brown so the
ico group is specifically attached to
the n so it's an acetyl group and it's
coming from glucose and specifically
glucosamine so that the the shortened
way to represent that is GLC for glucose
and an acetyl referring to that n group
being acetylated if there's no acetyl
group then it would just be without that
AC you just be cool close to mean like
that okay and then we also have we also
have a n acetyl galactose amine and so
that is different only in that
being down up down it's down up up here
so there's c4 epimer essentially and
instead of being represented as GLC and
they see its gal or for any galactose
and then AC also I showed the acetyl
group here a little bit differently just
a different way to represent it just in
case I show you one way or the other
they both mean the same thing but yeah
also that doesn't have to be a seat
elated it can just be galactose I mean
like that okay cool all right now there
are six classes of glycosaminoglycans
and they're classified based on a few
different things
they're based off
you